okay check this out
this is mamud gilma showing off an
astonishing ability to do something both
disgusting and amazing
how do you even learn to squirt milk out
of your eyes why would you do something
like that
as I say don't cry over spilled milk
this is crying via spilled milk but how
exactly does he do it I mean as you
somehow replumbed his face you ever
notice if you start crying tears come
out your eyes and these are of course
meant to coat your eyes and protect them
but your nose runs at the same time
there's a duct between the eye and the
nose that allows something to go out it
doesn't usually allow something to come
back in and out the eye the other way so
we've all got this duck but how does
Mahmud make it work backwards he does it
very simply with pressure so all he
needs to do is basically get the milk
into his nasal cavity and then breathe
in and don't agree that without
breathing out and then with that breast
to pressure inside him the liquid can
get his nose because he's holding it it
can't get out his mouth because it's
closed that liquid has to go somewhere
and where it goes is back up through the
lacrimal duct out his eye and into a
distant peak up this could potentially
be dangerous it might kind of wreck the
process of crying you don't wanna mess
about hi you order folks please don't
try this at home
guys this definitely won't get you the
girl